Hey guys, Craig Thomas here.
大家好，这里是克雷格·托马斯。
We have a special bonus episode we're sharing with you.
我们有一个特别的奖励剧集与您分享。
Carter Bays and I had a really cool experience recently where a script we wrote was brought back to life by a wonderful podcast called Dead Pilot Society.
卡特·贝斯和我最近有一次非常酷的经历，我们写的剧本被一个名为《死亡飞行员协会》的精彩播客复活了。
They take unproduced TV pilot scripts that they think are cool and organize a proper table read with a full cast of actors and kind of bring to life this pilot script that otherwise would be sitting on your shelf.
他们采用他们认为很酷的未制作的电视试播剧本，并组织一个适当的表格，与全体演员一起阅读，并让这个试播剧本变得栩栩如生，否则这个试播剧本就会放在你的架子上。
This was one we really loved.
这是我们真正喜欢的。
It's a pilot we wrote a couple years after how much a mother called Gimme 5 that combines our lives as comedy writers.
这是我们在《给我 5》的母亲几年后写的试播集，它结合了我们作为喜剧作家的生活。
It combines some stuff of my life as a parent.
它结合了我作为父母生活中的一些东西。
It had a lot of us in it, a lot of our personal lives, a lot of things we really care about, and it never even sold.
它里面有我们很多人，很多我们的个人生活，很多我们真正关心的东西，但它甚至从未被出售过。
It never got sold.
它从未被出售。
It never got shot.
它从来没有被枪杀过。
We never had a table read.
我们从来没有读过桌子。
But God bless Deadpile Society.
但上帝保佑死堆协会。
They brought this amazing cast together.
他们将这个令人惊叹的演员阵容聚集在一起。
They read it and they made this amazing podcast episode that we really wanted to share with you guys here I think how much other fans will really like this So please give it a listen.
他们阅读了它，并制作了这个令人惊叹的播客剧集，我们真的很想与大家分享，我想其他粉丝会非常喜欢这个，所以请听一听。
This is the only way you can possibly experience this TV script We're really really happy to share it with you.
这是您体验这个电视剧本的唯一方式我们真的很高兴与您分享。
Give a listen Welcome to dead pilot society the show that takes comedy pilots from a list writers that were sold and developed at networks and streamers But never produced and gives them the table reads they never got a chance to have.
欢迎来到《死亡飞行员社会》，该节目采用了名单作家的喜剧飞行员，这些作家在网络和流媒体上出售和开发，但从未制作过，并为他们提供了他们从未有机会拥有的表读物。
I am Andrew Reich, the creator and host of Dead Pilots Society, and it is week two of MaxFunDrive 2026.
我是安德鲁·赖克 (Andrew Reich)，《死亡飞行员协会》的创始人和主持人，现在是 MaxFunDrive 2026 的第二周。
We have just been delivering so much goodness to you, and we're not going to stop.
我们刚刚为您提供了如此多的善意，我们不会停止。
If you haven't yet, please consider becoming a member for as low as five dollars a month by going to maximumfund.org slash join dead pilots.
如果您还没有，请考虑访问Maximumfund.org，以每月低至五美元的价格成为会员。
We have our second dead pilot from Carter Bays and Craig Thomas for you.
我们为您准备了来自卡特·贝斯和克雷格·托马斯的第二名死去的飞行员。
This one's called give me five Carter and Craig of course co-created how I met your mother were showrunners for its entire nine year 208 episode run before that they were writers of the late show with David Letterman produces for American Dad, Carter is the author of the novel The Mutual Friend, and Craig is the author of the novel.
这部剧叫做《给我五个》，卡特和克雷格当然是共同创作的，他们是《我怎么认识你妈妈》的整个九年208集的制片人，之前他们是大卫·莱特曼为《美国爸爸》制作的后期剧的编剧，卡特是小说《共同的朋友》的作者，克雷格是小说的作者。
That's not how it happened.
事情并非如此。
Also, you should check out Craig's How I Met Your Mother Rewatch podcast called How We Made Your Mother.
另外，你应该看看克雷格的《老爸老妈浪漫史》重播播客，名为《我们如何造就你的母亲》。
Carter and Craig wrote this one with the legendary television writer Peter Tolin, whose credits include The Larry Sanders Show, Rescue Me, the movies analyze this and analyze that, tons of other.
卡特和克雷格与传奇电视作家彼得·托林（Peter Tolin）共同撰写了这一篇，彼得·托林的作品包括《拉里·桑德斯秀》、《救救我》、分析这个、分析那个的电影等等。
His resume is insane.
他的简历很疯狂。
I'm hoping to get another dead pilot from Peter at some point and get to talk to him because he's just an incredible writer.
我希望在某个时候能从彼得那里得到另一名死去的飞行员并与他交谈，因为他是一位令人难以置信的作家。
So the three of them teamed up for this pilot, Gimme 5.
于是他们三人联手制作了试播集《Gimme 5》。
Here's the logline.
这是日志行。
It's 1985 and Gimme 5 is the number two family sitcom in America.
1985 年，《给我 5》是美国排名第二的家庭情景喜剧。
But behind the scenes of this This feel-good show is a dysfunctional workplace family on the verge of self-destruction.
但在这部自我感觉良好的节目的幕后，却是一个处于自我毁灭边缘、功能失调的职场家庭。
Showrunner Cliff McConnell must somehow keep it together and keep being funny in the midst of his newborn son's health crisis.
该剧制片人克里夫·麦康奈尔必须想办法在刚出生的儿子的健康危机中保持镇静并保持幽默。
I really think this might be the most accurate depiction of a comedy writer's room that I've ever read.
我真的认为这可能是我读过的对喜剧作家房间最准确的描述。
I mean, this show is so funny and so wild.
我的意思是，这个节目是如此有趣，如此狂野。
warning major content warning definitely think twice about listening to this one with small children in the room and look you may hear something that offends you early on in this pilot but please stick with the show trust me it's one of the funniest pilots we've done on the podcast insane cast our cast for this one was as Cliff Taren Kilham from SNL and high potential as Dave Christian Montopolis from Silicon Valley and Beavis and Butthad as Shane Scott Foley from Scandal and Scream 7 as Boggs Dallas Gold Tooth from Reservation Dogs as Chaz and Penelope and the Topless Chick and Dr. Dingra Tammy Sager from Inside Amy Schumer and writing all of your favorite shows as Russell comedian Chris DeStefano as Jimmy James Urbaniac from Venture Brothers as Tanya Isabella Gomez from One Day at a Time, as Dottie, Alyssa Limparis from What We Do in the Shadows, as Chloe Serena Fiallo from Hy Potential and 9-1-1 Lone Star, and as Brains, Jamal, Kid One, the Assistant Director, Steve, and the Dr. Burl Mosley.
警告主要内容警告在房间里有小孩子的情况下听这个节目一定要三思而后行，你可能会在这个试播节目的早期听到一些冒犯你的东西，但请坚持看这个节目，相信我，这是我们在播客上做过的最有趣的试播节目之一，疯狂的演员阵容我们的演员阵容是来自 SNL 的 Cliff Taren Kilham 和来自硅谷的 Dave Christian Montopolis 的潜力巨大，以及来自 Scandal 和 Scream 的 Beavis 和 Butthad 饰演 Shane Scott Foley 7、在《保留狗》中饰演博格斯·达拉斯金牙，在《艾米·舒默内心》中饰演查兹和佩内洛普和裸照小鸡，以及在《艾米·舒默内心》中饰演丁格拉·塔米·萨格博士，并编写所有你最喜欢的节目，在《冒险兄弟》中饰演罗素喜剧演员克里斯·德斯特凡诺饰演吉米·詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克在《一天一次》中饰演坦尼娅·伊莎贝拉·戈麦斯，在《我们在阴影中做什么》中饰演多蒂，艾莉莎·林帕里斯在《我们在阴影中做什么》中饰演克洛伊·瑟琳娜《Hy Potential》和《9-1-1 Lone Star》中的 Fiallo，以及 Brains、Jamal、Kid One、助理导演 Steve 和 Burl Mosley 博士。
Man, this was such a good cast.
伙计，这真是一个很好的演员阵容。
This is such a fun one.
这真是一件有趣的事。
But before you start listening, why don't you go to maximumfund.org slash join dead pilots and become a member for as little as $5 a month.
但在您开始聆听之前，为什么不先访问Maximumfund.org，以每月低至5 美元的价格加入死亡飞行员行列并成为会员。
All right, here we go.
好吧，我们开始吧。
Buckle up, here's gimme five.
系好安全带，给我五个。
Carter and Craig, tell us a little bit about what we're about to hear.
卡特和克雷格，请告诉我们一些我们将要听到的内容。
Yeah, I can start this one off.
是的，我可以开始这个。
This is Craig, this is a single-cam pilot.
这是克雷格，这是一名单镜头飞行员。
We wrote maybe Carter, what do you think, 2016, 17, something like that?
我们可能写过卡特，你觉得怎么样，2016年，17日，类似的事情？
right after your mother ended a little bit after him you mended and we were trying to combine two two big parts of of our lives one was being writers in a writers room making a tv show and another one was that that i am the parent of a kid with a disability and uh there was this really interesting intersection in my life between year two and three of how much mother where my son was born with his medical complexities and he has arbierger neck syndrome not to get too heavy right off the bat on this one.
在你母亲去世后不久，你就修补了，我们试图将我们生活中的两个重要部分结合起来，一个是在作家室里做一个电视节目的作家，另一个是我是一个残疾孩子的父母，呃，在我的第二年和第三年之间，我的生活中有一个非常有趣的交集，我的儿子出生时有多少母亲患有他的医疗复杂性，他患有阿尔比尔格颈综合症，不要在这件事上立即变得太沉重。
But it was this fun, it was this strange phenomenon of, I was like in the neonatal intensive care unit with my son and then commuting into the how I met your mother writer's room.
但这很有趣，这是一种奇怪的现象，我就像和儿子一起在新生儿重症监护室，然后通勤到我如何遇见你母亲作家的房间。
And it was like, I was living between these crazy two worlds of like a sitcom and then like this very heavy like medical drama that my life had become.
就好像，我生活在这两个疯狂的世界之间，就像一部情景喜剧，然后就像我的生活变得非常沉重，就像医疗剧一样。
By the way, my son's 18 and doing great right now.
顺便说一句，我儿子 18 岁了，现在过得很好。
I will say that right now to make it a little lighter.
我现在就这么说是为了让它轻松一点。
But it was this insane time and I would show up and Carter and I would look at each other and go, Now go be funny.
但在这个疯狂的时刻，我会出现，卡特和我会互相看着对方，然后说，现在去搞笑吧。
That was sort of our mantra like every morning.
这就像我们每天早上的口头禅一样。
And that's the title of this pilot, right?
这就是这位飞行员的头衔，对吧？
Carter and Carter was very much in all of that with me.
卡特和卡特对我来说非常重要。
So that that informs this pilot a lot.
这给这位飞行员带来了很多信息。
The one thing I would add about that is it's and I reading this now, especially in the age of like seeing what's kind of happened to the TV industry since we wrote this in the 10 years.
我要补充的一件事是，我现在正在读这篇文章，尤其是在这个时代，我们想看看自从我们写这篇文章以来的十年里电视行业发生了什么。
So much of the show I feel like is about our experience in writers' rooms and the way that that those writers' rooms were sort of this conduit of continuity of the craft of TV writing that spanned back to the beginning.
我觉得这部剧的大部分内容都是关于我们在编剧室的经历，以及这些编剧室是电视写作工艺从一开始就延续的管道。
We worked on how many of your mother with writers from Frasier, and they worked with writers from Cheers, and they worked with writers from Taxi, going all the way back to your show of shows or whatever.
我们研究了你的母亲中有多少人与《欢乐时光》的编剧合作，他们与《欢呼》的编剧合作，他们与《出租车》的编剧合作，一直追溯到你的节目或其他什么。
And so in the writers' rooms, you would just hear all these great stories, these legends, this lore of things that happen.
因此，在作家的房间里，你只会听到所有这些伟大的故事、这些传说、这些发生的事情的传说。
And you'll hear in this, the Mr. Belvedere thing is like a perfect example.
你会听到，贝尔维德尔先生的事情就是一个完美的例子。
That's sort of broken through into the real world, and people know that reference, but I just feel like we had this treasure trove of great stories that we've heard, and this felt like a way to create a show that just tells all these stories and sort of dumps all these anecdotes into one container.
这有点突破了现实世界，人们知道这个参考，但我只是觉得我们拥有我们听过的伟大故事的宝库，这感觉就像是创建一个节目的一种方式，只讲述所有这些故事，并将所有这些轶事转储到一个容器中。
So yeah, that's what makes me sad about sort of like the way, I feel like writers' rooms have sort of disappeared, at least writers' rooms as we knew them back then, And so this is sort of like a way to preserve that.
所以，是的，这就是让我感到悲伤的原因，我觉得作家的房间已经消失了，至少是我们当时所知道的作家的房间，所以这有点像保存它的一种方式。
And we should acknowledge that you had another person writing this with you.
我们应该承认，有另一个人和你一起写这篇文章。
Yes, yes, the great Peter Toland, who is like a hero of ours who, I mean, we were such fans of Larry Sanders and of rescue me, and so it was great just getting his input and his, he's been doing this forever also.
是的，是的，伟大的彼得·托兰，他就像我们的英雄，我的意思是，我们都是拉里·桑德斯和拯救我的粉丝，所以很高兴得到他的意见和他的，他也一直在这样做。
And so it was, he was a great addition to the team.
事实也是如此，他对团队来说是一个很好的补充。
Yeah, there's definitely some Larry Sanders in this pilot, for sure, so it was great to have him working on it with us.
是的，这部试播节目中肯定有一些拉里·桑德斯，所以很高兴让他和我们一起工作。
Yes, well, I've rarely been so excited to hear a pilot read.
是的，嗯，我很少如此兴奋地听到飞行员朗读。
I can't wait for this.
我等不及了。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
We will talk more later.
我们稍后会详细讨论。
And now here is Gimme Five, the pilot, Now Gobi Funny, written by Carter Bayes and Craig Thomas and Peter Tolen.
现在请听《给我五》，试播集《现在戈壁搞笑》，由卡特·贝叶斯、克雷格·托马斯和彼得·托伦编剧。
We fade in.
我们淡入。
We're in an upper east side luxury high rise building, pleasant music as we push in on the penthouse apartment.
我们身处上东区的一栋豪华高层建筑中，当我们推入顶层公寓时，伴随着悦耳的音乐。
It's the Pendleton living room.
这是彭德尔顿的客厅。
The year is 1985 and we're watching a hit family sitcom.
1985 年，我们正在观看一部热门家庭情景喜剧。
A family sits around a coffee table playing monopoly.
一家人围坐在咖啡桌旁玩垄断游戏。
They are Lacey, 15, the responsible one.
他们就是 15 岁的莱西，负责人。
Chaz, 14, the dumb one.
查兹，14岁，傻瓜。
Brains, 12, the smart one.
大脑，12岁，聪明的一个。
Jamal, 11, the black one.
贾马尔，11 岁，黑人。
Penelope, 10, the cute one.
佩内洛普，10 岁，很可爱。
and their adoptive dad, Mr. Pendleton, AKA Mr. P, 50's distinguished rich guy.
还有他们的养父彭德尔顿先生，又名 P 先生，是 50 年代的杰出富翁。
The large penthouse apartment is decorated for Christmas.
大型顶层公寓已进行圣诞节装饰。
Yo, Mr. P, how'd you get so good at Monopoly anyway?
哟，P 先生，你怎么能把大富翁玩得这么好呢？
Well, Jamal, until recently making money was the only thing I cared about, but I was empty inside.
好吧，贾马尔，直到最近赚钱还是我唯一关心的事情，但我内心却很空虚。
When I'm empty inside, I eat pizza.
当我内心空虚的时候，我就吃披萨。
Not that kind of empty jazz, but then I went down to the orphanage and adopted the five of you and it's like I landed on boardwalk.
不是那种空洞的爵士乐，但后来我去了孤儿院并收养了你们五个，就像我降落在木板路上一样。
Oh, Boardwalk's mine.
哦，海滨大道是我的。
That'll be a hundred.
那将是一百。
Hey.
嘿。
He gives Lacey a why you little look.
他给了莱西一个“为什么你这么少”的表情。
Okay, bedtime and don't forget your prayers.
好吧，睡觉时间到了，别忘了祈祷。
Penelope asks.
佩内洛普问道。
Mr. P, I've been wondering, does God have an answering machine?
P先生，我一直想知道，上帝有电话答录机吗？
Now why don't you wonder that?
现在你为什么不好奇呢？
I have an important prayer and I don't want him to miss it.
我有一个重要的祈祷，我不想让他错过。
Adoy.
阿杜伊。
So, what do you want to say to the big guy?
那么，你有什么想对大佬说的吗？
Thank you for sending us a daddy.
谢谢你给我们送来了一位爸爸。
Aww.
哇。
Well, if you get him on the line, tell him I said thanks for sending me you, all of you.
好吧，如果你给他打电话，请告诉他我说感谢你们所有人派我来。
And since he's so all-knowing, can you also ask him where I put my keys?
既然他这么无所不知，你能问他我把钥匙放在哪里了吗？
You lost your keys again?
你又丢钥匙了吗？
Uh oh.
呃哦。
And the audience goes bananas, that's our catchphrase.
观众会疯狂，这是我们的口号。
After the laughter dies down, Mr. Pendleton just looks at Penelope for a beat.
笑声平息后，彭德尔顿先生只是看了一眼佩内洛普。
And then, matter of fact...
然后，事实上...
Oh, Penelope.
哦，佩内洛普。
Suck my balls.
吸我的球。
And we hard cut out to the writer's room.
我们硬是切到了作家的房间。
We get a huge laugh from the writers, seated around a table littered with old scripts, take out condiments, pads and pencils, snack containers, and a half-finished bottle of Jack Daniels.
我们坐在一张堆满旧剧本的桌子周围，拿出调味品、便签本、铅笔、零食容器和一瓶喝了一半的杰克丹尼啤酒，得到了编剧们的大笑。
We're not in sitcom 1985 anymore.
我们已经不再是情景喜剧 1985 了。
This is actual 1985.
这是真实的1985年。
A nervous writer's assistant, Steve, 22, waits at a typewriter, a couple of the writers smoke, smoke indoors cliff McConnell 30s the creator showrunner the grown up in a room full of children stands before them holding the script pages he's just read the loud what we've been watching isn't a real episode it's a rewrite in progress oh Penelope suck my balls okay why is it every time that I leave the room for five minutes I come back and what used to be a cute sweet little script is now gasping for air under an avalanche of dick and balls.
一个紧张的编剧助理，史蒂夫，22岁，在打字机前等待，几个编剧在室内抽烟，悬崖麦康奈尔30多岁，创作者剧集主管，在一个满是孩子的房间里长大，站在他们面前，拿着剧本页，他刚刚大声朗读我们一直在看的不是真正的剧集，而是正在重写哦，佩内洛普吸我的蛋蛋，好吧，为什么每次我离开房间五分钟我都会回来，以前是什么是一个可爱的小脚本，现在在雪崩般的鸡巴和睾丸下喘着粗气。
Marty Boggs, 30s, sweat stains and self-loathing chimes in.
马蒂·博格斯 (Marty Boggs)，30 多岁，汗迹和自我厌恶感相辅相成。
Because unlike most of the shit we write, this actually gets a laugh.
因为与我们写的大多数狗屎不同，这实际上会让人发笑。
Yeah, from a room full of retards, can we please just write things that actually go on TV?
是的，在一个充满智障的房间里，我们可以写一些实际在电视上播出的东西吗？
Yes, no dicks, no balls?
是的，没有鸡巴，没有蛋蛋？
The lone female writer, Sarah Wylam, 20s, Mousey, chimes in.
20 多岁的孤独女作家莎拉·威拉姆 (Sarah Wylam) 也插话道。
Oh, an L.A.P.
哦，L.A.P.
Suck my nuts.
吸我的坚果。
Yeah, good fix, let's put that in.
是的，很好的修复，让我们把它放进去。
The writer's assistant, Steve, starts loudly typing.
作者的助理史蒂夫开始大声打字。
Not really Steve.
不完全是史蒂夫。
Steve stops typing, takes the page out and crumbles it up.
史蒂夫停止打字，拿出纸页并将其揉碎。
Hey, speaking of nuts, did you guys hear about Mr. Belvedere?
嘿，说到坚果，你们听说过 Belvedere 先生吗？
Sniff, Russell, 20s, a standup, endlessly cheerful and peppy, comes up from a huge line of Coke.
Sniff，Russell，20 多岁，是一位单口喜剧演员，充满活力，充满活力，来自可口可乐的大生产线。
What about Mr. Belvedere?
贝尔韦代雷先生呢？
A buddy of mine is a writer over there.
我的一个朋友是那里的作家。
Good morning at the table read, Mr. Belvedere walks in, you know, big fattening, he's wearing this track suit, no underwear.
餐桌上读着“早上好”，贝尔维代尔先生走进来，你知道，胖胖的，他穿着这套运动服，没有穿内衣。
He sits down in his chair, it crushes his own nuts.
他坐在椅子上，椅子压碎了他的心。
The writers all react with astonishment and delight.
作家们的反应都是惊讶和喜悦。
They're shut down for a month.
他们被关了一个月。
But the show or is nuts?
但这个节目还是疯了？
That's your first episode back.
这是你回来的第一集。
There's a mysterious helium leak.
发生了神秘的氦气泄漏。
What do you say?
你怎么说？
Have you finished your homework?
你作业做完了吗？
Russell laughs way too hard at his own jokes.
拉塞尔对自己的笑话笑得太厉害了。
This is all gold.
这都是金子。
Get this down.
把这个记下来。
Steve starts loudly typing Cliff's size again.
史蒂夫再次开始大声输入克里夫的尺码。
Not really Steve.
不完全是史蒂夫。
Jesus.
耶稣。
Sweating a bit, Steve takes the page out and crumples it up.
史蒂夫出汗了，拿出纸页，揉皱起来。
Okay, enough fucking around.
好吧，他妈的够了。
We're not staying for dinner.
我们不留下来吃晚饭。
I have to go to rehearsal.
我得去排练。
Jimmy, take over.
吉米，接手吧。
Jimmy Deason, 50's cold and logical.
吉米·迪森 (Jimmy Deason)，50 岁，冷酷而有逻辑。
A comedy writer version of Mr. Spock looks up from his Columbia House catalog.
喜剧作家版的斯波克先生从他的哥伦比亚之家目录中查找。
Hi, Captain.
嗨，队长。
Sorry.
对不起。
up for Columbia House, 12 tapes to repenting up there.
哥伦比亚之家，有 12 盘磁带可供忏悔。
Jimmy moves into Cliff's seat next to the typewriter.
吉米搬到克里夫打字机旁边的座位上。
Boggs rolls his eyes, Sarah pulls Cliff aside.
博格斯翻了个白眼，莎拉把克里夫拉到一边。
I don't want to say this in front of the guys, but are we really not staying for dinner?
我不想在大家面前说这些，但是我们真的不留下来吃晚饭吗？
I have a date tonight, I really like this guy.
今晚我有个约会，我真的很喜欢这个人。
Yes, Sarah, you will make your date.
是的，莎拉，你会和你约会的。
We're not staying for dinner.
我们不留下来吃晚饭。
Cliff exits, Sarah turns around to the writers who are all grinning at her.
克利夫退出后，莎拉转身面对那些都对她微笑的编剧们。
So this date.
所以这个日期。
Sarah sinks into her chair to take what will surely be a 20 minute riff on her sex life as Boggs exits.
当博格斯退出时，莎拉坐在椅子上，对她的性生活进行了 20 分钟的即兴表演。
When the Give Me Five production office continues, Boggs catches up with Cliff in the hallway.
当《给我五》制作办公室继续进行时，博格斯在走廊里追上了克里夫。
Hey, boss.
嘿，老板。
All right, Boggs, I'm not having this conversation again.
好吧，博格斯，我不会再进行这样的谈话了。
When I'm out of the room, Jimmy's in charge.
当我离开房间时，吉米负责。
They were definitely staying for dinner because that guy should not be running a room.
他们肯定会留下来吃晚饭，因为那个人不应该管理一个房间。
Jimmy has been doing this for a long time.
吉米这样做已经很长时间了。
Jimmy does everything a long time.
吉米做每件事都花了很长时间。
Have you watched him eat?
你看过他吃饭吗？
Guy chews every bit, every bite 25 times.
盖伊每一口都咀嚼 25 次。
I've counted.
我数过。
25.
Don't believe me.
别相信我。
Comment tonight.
今晚评论一下。
We'll definitely stay for dinner.
我们一定会留下来吃晚饭。
Go back in the room, Boggs.
回到房间去，博格斯。
We're not staying for dinner.
我们不留下来吃晚饭。
Boggs goes back in the room.
博格斯回到房间。
Cliff's assistant, Dottie, in her 20s, fiercely loyal, would kill for him, appears.
克里夫的助手多蒂 (Dottie) 20 多岁，极其忠诚，愿意为他杀人。
There you are.
你就在那里。
Hi.
你好。
Can you tell production that we are staying for dinner?
你能告诉制作组我们要留下来吃晚饭吗？
Chloe's on the phone.
克洛伊正在打电话。
She's in labor.
她正在临产。
No, she's not.
不，她不是。
Yes, she is.
是的，她是。
Cliff Smiles fondly picks up the phone.
克里夫·斯迈尔斯深情地拿起电话。
No, you're not.
不，你不是。
And Cliff and Chloe's modest house we intercut.
我们还切入了克里夫和克洛伊简朴的房子。
Cliff's wife, Chloe, pretty sweet, a little needy and lonely is nine months pregnant.
克里夫的妻子克洛伊 (Chloe) 非常可爱，但有点贫困和孤独，已经怀孕九个月了。
She smiles mischievous.
她顽皮地笑着。
No, I'm not.
不，我不是。
But this is the only way I can get you on the phone.
但这是我可以给你打电话的唯一方法。
Ah, I'm sorry I didn't build the crib last night.
啊，很抱歉昨晚我没有建造婴儿床。
I will do it tonight.
今晚我会做的。
Well, too late.
好吧，太晚了。
I did it this morning.
我今天早上做到了。
You built a crib, nine months pregnant.
你建造了一张婴儿床，怀孕九个月了。
Man, I am an asshole.
伙计，我是个混蛋。
I can do lots of things nine months pregnant.
怀孕九个月我可以做很多事情。
Get home before midnight sometime and I'll show you.
午夜之前回家，我会告诉你。
Cancel rehearsal, I'm on my way.
取消排练，我正在路上。
Chloe smiles, then, with a hint of sadness.
克洛伊微笑着，带着一丝悲伤。
Oh, no, you're not.
哦，不，你不是。
Chloe hangs up on him.
克洛伊挂断了他的电话。
It's mostly playful, but Cliff sinks a bit.
这主要是好玩的，但克里夫有点下沉。
Dottie has eagerly picked up the phone and dialed.
多蒂迫不及待地拿起电话拨通了电话。
Rehearsals canceled.
排练取消了。
Cliffs eyes and takes the phone from Dottie.
Cliff眼神一亮，从Dottie手里接过电话。
Rehearsals not canceled.
排练没有取消。
Where the hell is Dave?
戴夫到底在哪里？
The studio entrance, a lipstick red Ferrari testerosa, pulls up to the studio entrance.
工作室门口，一辆口红红色的法拉利testerosa，停在工作室入口处。
Two 10 year old boys happen to be riding by on their bikes.
两个 10 岁的男孩碰巧骑着自行车经过。
They see this car and their worlds are rocked.
他们看到这辆车，他们的世界都震惊了。
A Ferrari tester Rosa.
法拉利测试员罗莎.
Attico.
阿蒂科。
Behind the wheel of the Ferrari is Dave Gold.
驾驶法拉利的是戴夫·戈尔德 (Dave Gold)。
30s, the director of Gimme 5.
30多岁，《给我5》的导演。
Think successful Hollywood director, 1985, and that's Dave.
想想 1985 年成功的好莱坞导演，那就是戴夫。
Hair blow-dried, blazer sleeves rolled up, skinny tie.
头发吹干，西装外套袖子卷起，系着细领带。
He peers over the top of his Ray bands, flashes them a winning smile and revs the engine.
他透过射线带的顶部凝视着他们，向他们露出胜利的微笑，然后启动了引擎。
The kids eat this up, high-fiving, as he roars onto the lot.
当他咆哮着冲进场地时，孩子们把它吃光了，击掌。
On the soundstage, the Ferrari parks in the spot outside the soundstage, the Ferrari parks in the spot marked Dave Gold, director.
摄影棚里，法拉利停在了摄影棚外的位置，法拉利停在的位置标有导演戴夫·戈尔德（Dave Gold）。
He climbs out, cliff awaits.
他爬了出去，悬崖就在前方等待着他。
Got a close, where were you?
快结束了，你在哪里？
Just doing some light reading.
只是做一些轻松的阅读。
He holds up a TV guide with Mr Pendleton on the cover.
他举起一本电视指南，封面上有彭德尔顿先生。
The caption reads, America's favorite TV dad.
标题写着：美国最受欢迎的电视爸爸。
In its second season, Gimme Five is America's number two comedy second only to different strokes.
在第二季中，《给我五》成为美国排名第二的喜剧，仅次于《不同的笔画》。
fucking strokes.
他妈的笔画。
But the mad cap zanyness of gimme five is tops in at least one house.
但《给我五》的疯狂滑稽程度至少在一所房子里是最高的。
The White House as president Reagan gushed in a recent interview while most of Hollywood has forgotten about good old fashioned blah blah blah.
里根总统在最近的一次采访中滔滔不绝地谈论白宫，而好莱坞的大多数人已经忘记了老式的废话。
A bunch of dicks bit about morality.
一群混蛋热衷于道德。
Gimme five stands alone as an example of real American family values.
给我五是真正美国家庭价值观的典范。
I had cap zanyness.
我有滑稽的帽子。
I'd like to think what we do is grounded character driven Cliff Cliff Bubby force for the trees the Reagan's love us.
我想我们所做的就是扎根性格驱动的悬崖悬崖巴比力量，为里根爱我们的树木服务。
This show is going to run forever syndication, baby.
这个节目将永远联合播出，宝贝。
All right, let's not count our chickens.
好吧，我们别数鸡了。
Who's counting chickens?
谁在数鸡？
Cliff points to Dave's Ferrari license plate.
克里夫指着戴夫的法拉利车牌。
Sendic eight.
森迪克八.
Dave smiles slightly sheepish, but not really.
戴夫笑得有点羞涩，但其实并非如此。
It's only season two.
这只是第二季。
A lot can happen between now and syndication.
从现在到联合组织之间可能会发生很多事情。
Do you hear about Mr. Belvedere?
你听说过贝尔韦代雷先生吗？
Sad on his nuts.
为他的疯子感到难过。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh.
哦。
Cliff enters the sound stage and Dave follows.
克里夫进入摄影棚，戴夫紧随其后。
On the Give Me Five sound stage, in addition to the Give Me Five sets, Pendleton living room, kitchen, kids bedrooms, etc., there are bleachers for the studio audience.
在《给我五》摄影棚里，除了《给我五》布景、彭德尔顿客厅、厨房、儿童卧室等，还有为演播室观众准备的看台。
The cast and crew mill about pre rehearsal.
演员和工作人员正在讨论排练前的情况。
Shane Winters, the actor who plays Mr Pendleton, approaches Cliff and Dave.
扮演彭德尔顿先生的演员肖恩·温特斯接近克里夫和戴夫。
Unlike his lovable TV persona, Shane is mysterious, hard to read, a bit creepy at times, a serious stage actor who brings an intensity to all of his roles.
与他可爱的电视角色不同，肖恩是一个神秘、难以理解、有时有点令人毛骨悚然的人，他是一位严肃的舞台演员，为他的所有角色带来了强度。
Big dog!
大狗！
Hey, did you hear about Mr Belvedere?
嘿，你听说贝尔韦代雷先生了吗？
Shane turns to Dave, whom he hates.
谢恩转向他讨厌的戴夫。
You mean, did I hear about my dear friend Chris Hewitt, who recently suffered a very traumatic and very private injury?
你的意思是，我听说过我亲爱的朋友克里斯·休伊特（Chris Hewitt）的事吗？他最近遭受了非常严重且非常私密的伤害？
What about him, Dave?
他呢，戴夫？
He sat on his nuts.
他坐立不安。
Shane stares at Dave witheringly, but Cliff jumps in.
肖恩冷酷地盯着戴夫，但克里夫插话了。
Hey, Shane, you see this?
嘿，谢恩，你看到这个了吗？
America's favorite TV dad.
美国最受欢迎的电视爸爸。
Cliff hands Shane the TV guide, he smirks at it.
克里夫把电视指南递给肖恩，肖恩对着它傻笑。
Not exactly my Tony for American Buffalo, but I suppose one could rest a cocktail on this.
不完全是我的美国布法罗托尼，但我想人们可以在上面喝一杯鸡尾酒。
Shane tosses it onto a table, it slides to the floor.
肖恩把它扔到桌子上，它滑到地板上。
A couple of questions on the script here where my character says, kids, my dad taught me to swim the old-fashioned way, throwing me in the deep end and letting me sink.
关于剧本的几个问题，我的角色说，孩子们，我爸爸教我用老式的方式游泳，把我扔进深水区，让我沉下去。
You see the problem, right?
你看到问题了，对吧？
Well, it's a joke, too harsh.
好吧，这就是个玩笑，太严厉了。
Shane stares a cliff like he's unspeakable dim.
谢恩凝视着悬崖，眼神黯淡得难以形容。
My character doesn't have a father.
我的角色没有父亲。
He doesn't.
他不知道。
Mr Pendleton's father is dead.
彭德尔顿先生的父亲去世了。
Suicide.
自杀。
Oh.
哦。
Okay.
好的。
Um, have we indicated that at any point on the show?
嗯，我们在节目中的任何时候都表明过这一点吗？
Shane again looks at Cliff like he's an imbecile.
谢恩再次用看傻子的眼神看着克里夫。
It's all over the show, Cliff.
这一切都在演出中，克里夫。
It is the show.
这是表演。
It's, it's the subtext of the show.
这是，这就是节目的潜台词。
Mr P's father's death is the reason he took these five kids in to spare them the emptiness he spent his whole life running from, but hey, it's not like this one joke undermines my entire understanding of the character.
P先生父亲的去世是他收养这五个孩子的原因，是为了让他们摆脱他一生都在逃避的空虚感，但是，嘿，这并不是说这个笑话破坏了我对这个角色的整个理解。
Let's leave it in.
我们把它留在里面吧。
Well, we'll cut the joke.
好吧，我们就别开玩笑了。
Would you?
你愿意吗？
I don't want to meddle.
我不想插手。
It's an easy fix to preserve crucial backstories done.
这是保存已完成的重要背景故事的简单修复方法。
Good.
好的。
Just a few more questions.
还有几个问题。
Shane flips through more pages rife with dog ears and post-its.
肖恩翻阅了更多充满狗耳朵和便利贴的页面。
Cliff and Dave sink until they hear an assistant director circle up everyone.
克里夫和戴夫陷入沉思，直到他们听到副导演把所有人围起来。
Alas, to be continued.
唉，未完待续。
Great notes, Big Dog, always a privilege to get inside that brain.
很棒的笔记，大狗，进入那个大脑总是一种荣幸。
Shane joins the circle.
谢恩加入了这个圈子。
Cliff and Dave Sigh, relieved.
克里夫和戴夫松了一口气。
Thank God.
感谢上帝。
Literally.
字面上地。
Prayer Circle time, everyone.
各位，祈祷圈时间到了。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
in reverse.
相反。
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at Hyper-FixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 Hyper-FixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
Tanya Ray Richmond, the barely 18-year-old Southern actress who plays Mr. B's eldest daughter, 15-year-old Lacey, walks the line between wholesome and troublingly sexual, stands Because at the center of a large circle of cast and crew, none of whom seem particularly into this whole prayer circle thing.
坦尼娅·雷·里士满 (Tanya Ray Richmond) 是一位年仅 18 岁的南方女演员，饰演 B 先生的大女儿，15 岁的莱西 (Lacey)，她游走在健康与令人不安的性之间，因为她站在一大群演员和工作人员的中心，而他们似乎都不太热衷于整个祈祷圈的事情。
Prayer circle.
祈祷圈。
Everyone line up for the prayer circle.
每个人都排队进入祈祷圈。
Pat Kenny?
帕特·肯尼？
The AD barks a two stage hand smoking by the props card.
广告在道具卡旁边咆哮着两阶段的手抽烟。
Pat is telling Kenny about fucking some girl.
帕特正在告诉肯尼他要操一个女孩。
The way we know this is that Pat is miming fucking a girl from behind while grabbing her tits.
我们知道这一点的方式是，帕特一边模仿着从后面操一个女孩，一边抓住她的乳房。
Not damn it you assholes, it's time for the prayer circle.
别操你们这些混蛋，现在是祈祷圈的时间了。
Sorry, Tonya Ray.
对不起，托尼娅·雷。
Tonya Ray smiles politely as Pat and Kenny join the large prayer circle.
当帕特和肯尼加入大祈祷圈时，托尼娅·雷礼貌地微笑着。
do Cliff and Dave.
克里夫和戴夫也这么做。
Please join hands y'all.
请大家携起手来。
Everyone does so.
每个人都这样做。
Dave has to hold Pat's hand.
戴夫必须握住帕特的手。
Cliff, Kenny's.
克里夫，肯尼的。
They are not the cleanest hands in the world.
他们不是世界上最干净的手。
Dear Lord, let us have a blessed rehearsal.
亲爱的主，让我们有一个蒙福的排练。
Let thy holy light shine upon us for thy art thou maker and thy art thou shepherd.
让你的圣光照耀我们，因为你是你的创造者，你是你的牧者。
And ye have makeeth thou children in thine image.
你们也照着自己的形像生了儿女。
Is this Leviticus?
这是利未记吗？
I believe it's bullshiticus.
我相信这是胡说八道。
Dave and Cliff stifle a laugh.
戴夫和克里夫忍住笑。
back on Tanya still talking.
回到塔尼娅仍在说话。
And now a moment of silent prayer.
现在是默祷的时刻。
Everyone obeys but Cliff notices something.
每个人都服从，但克里夫注意到了一些事情。
In the prayer circle Tanya happens to be holding hands with Shane and Shane just happens to be subtly caressing her hand with his fingers.
在祈祷圈中，塔尼娅碰巧与谢恩牵着手，而谢恩恰好用手指巧妙地爱抚着她的手。
She smiles coyly at him.
她对他腼腆地笑了笑。
Cliff's eyes widen.
克里夫睁大了眼睛。
He nudges Dave who follows his gaze and notices yikes.
他碰了碰戴夫，戴夫顺着他的目光看去，注意到了他的叫声。
In the parking lot moments later Cliff horrified and Dave in denial exit the stage tell me you saw that I don't know what I saw you saw the next cover of TV guide America's favorite TV dad fucking his daughter no way he was just being fatherly do you think Tonya Ray's actual father touches her like that well she is from the south look even if there were something going on which there's not Tonya Ray's 18 it's it's okay she plays his daughter if you found out that Punky Brewster was blowing Henry between takes with that be okay.
过了一会儿，在停车场，克利夫惊恐万状，戴夫否认，退出舞台告诉我，你看到了，我不知道我看到了什么，你看到了电视指南的下一个封面，美国最喜欢的电视爸爸操他的女儿，不可能，他只是慈父，你认为托尼娅·雷的亲生父亲对她的触感很好吗？她来自南方，即使发生了一些事情，没有托尼娅·雷的18岁，如果你发现，她扮演他的女儿也没关系庞基·布鲁斯特在拍摄间隙吹亨利，没关系。
If it turned out that George and ma'am were secretly double teaming Webster, would you still enjoy that show if Phil Cosby.
如果事实证明乔治和夫人正在秘密包夹韦伯斯特，你还会喜欢菲尔·科斯比的那个节目吗？
Okay.
好的。
It's not okay.
这不行。
This gets out.
这事就出去了。
We will get canceled.
我们将会被取消。
All of this goes away.
所有这一切都会消失。
The house, the girls, the car.
房子，女孩，车子。
Okay.
好的。
Let's get Steve's attention.
让我们引起史蒂夫的注意。
Yes.
是的。
You're right.
你说得对。
I, I, uh, okay.
我，我，呃，好吧。
I guess you better talk to Shane.
我想你最好和谢恩谈谈。
Fuck you, you're the director.
操你妈，你是导演。
You put out a fire for once, okay?
你把火扑灭一次，好吗？
Jesus Christ.
耶稣基督。
Cliff's assistant, Dottie, runs up excited.
克里夫的助手多蒂兴奋地跑过来。
Cliff, your wife's in labor.
克里夫，你妻子正在临产。
Oh, Dottie, she's not in labor.
哦，多蒂，她没有临产。
That's just a running joke that we...
这只是一个笑话，我们...
Cliff, she's in labor for real.
克里夫，她真的要临产了。
Beat as this registers, Cliff slowly starts to smile.
当这一切记录下来时，克里夫慢慢地开始微笑。
Holy shit.
天哪。
I'm gonna be a dad.
我要当爸爸了
Congrats.
恭喜。
Dave hugs Cliff, who then runs off.
戴夫拥抱了克里夫，克里夫随后跑开了。
Okay, and don't worry, we'll hold down the fort, all right?
好吧，别担心，我们会坚守堡垒，好吗？
All right, and we'll just hit pause on that other little thing for now.
好吧，我们现在暂停一下其他小事。
There's a beat.
有一个节拍。
Cliff runs back in.
克里夫跑了回来。
Deal with it today.
今天就处理一下。
Cliff runs back out as Dave Smile disappears.
当戴夫·斯迈尔消失时，克里夫跑了出去。
In the Pendleton penthouse living room at night, we're watching another scene from the Gimme 5 Christmas episode, Mr. P and the five kids decorated Christmas tree.
晚上，在彭德尔顿顶层公寓的客厅里，我们正在观看《给我 5》圣诞节剧集中的另一个场景，P 先生和五个孩子装饰圣诞树。
Mr. P is in a super 80s Christmas sweater.
P先生穿着一件超级80年代的圣诞毛衣。
What tree should we leave on the mantle for Santa?
我们应该在圣诞老人的地幔上留下什么树？
By my calculations, Santa flies around the entire circumference circumference of the Earth, 24,859.82 miles.
根据我的计算，圣诞老人绕地球一周飞行了 24,859.82 英里。
Thus, his treat should be protein-based, vanilla ice cream with almonds.
因此，他的食物应该是基于蛋白质的香草冰淇淋和杏仁。
Ice cream.
冰淇淋。
Santa's been freezing his petite off in the North Pole.
圣诞老人在北极把他的小孩子冻坏了。
He wants hot chocolate.
他想要热巧克力。
Did someone say hot chocolate?
有人说热巧克力吗？
Jamal punctuates this with a completely out of context breakdance move.
贾马尔用一个完全断章取义的霹雳舞动作来强调这一点。
The audience whoops and claps along with the music that starts playing as Jamal dances.
随着贾马尔跳舞，观众们随着音乐开始欢呼鼓掌。
We hard cut out to the writer's room.
我们硬着头皮去了作家的房间。
Boggs reading this script page interjects with disgust.
博格斯读到这个剧本页时感到厌恶。
Then he just does a dance for no goddamn reason.
然后他就毫无理由地跳舞了。
The audience likes it when Jamal chives out to a funky urban groove.
观众喜欢贾马尔跳出时髦的都市节奏。
Just get to the joke.
直接讲笑话吧。
Right so he does a breakdance and then Penelope says.
是的，他跳了一支霹雳舞，然后佩内洛普说道。
And in the Pendleton Penhouse living room as they were.
就在彭德尔顿阁楼的客厅里。
Mr. Pete, what treat do you think Santa wants?
皮特先生，你认为圣诞老人想要什么礼物？
Oh, nothing much.
哦，没什么。
Just a Porsche 944.
只是一辆保时捷 944。
The studio audience laughs, charmed, but it turns into dead silence in the writer's room.
演播室里的观众笑得很开心，但编剧的房间里却陷入了死一般的寂静。
All the writers just stare at Jimmy.
所有的作家都只是盯着吉米。
That's not funny.
这不好笑。
Sure it is.
当然是。
No, it's not.
不，不是。
It's just him saying a kind of car.
他只是说一种汽车。
Well, it's funny in several ways.
嗯，这在很多方面都很有趣。
First, there's a reversal when Mr. P says, oh, nothing much, we expect what comes next to be something inexpensive.
首先，P 先生说，哦，没什么，我们预计接下来会出现一些便宜的东西，情况发生了逆转。
However, a base model portion 944 lists at about $20,000, so there's absurdity at work there.
然而，944 的基本型号部分标价约为 20,000 美元，因此其中存在荒谬之处。
Second, we're implying that since Santa is really Mr. P, he's the one who knows what Santa really wants, so the second way it's funny is as a sly wink to the grown-ups.
其次，我们暗示，既然圣诞老人真的是 P 先生，他就是那个知道圣诞老人真正想要什么的人，所以第二种有趣的方式是对大人狡猾地眨眼。
The third way is incongruity, a traditional trade for Santa would be a sweet at some kind, such as brownies, not a high performance, luxury automobile.
第三种方式是不协调，圣诞老人的传统交易可能是某种甜食，例如布朗尼蛋糕，而不是高性能的豪华汽车。
Those are the three ways, it's funny.
这就是这三种方式，很有趣。
Another long silent beat as the writers stare at Jimmy.
作家们盯着吉米，又是一阵长时间的沉默。
Oh, yeah, you're right.
哦，是的，你是对的。
It's fucking hilarious.
真是太搞笑了
Jimmy, you're running the room.
吉米，你负责管理这个房间。
If you like the show, let's just put it in and move on.
如果您喜欢这个节目，我们就把它放进去然后继续。
exactly what Sarah's good to see later on her date.
这正是莎拉在约会后很高兴看到的。
All eyes turn to Jimmy.
所有的目光都转向吉米。
Jimmy leans back in his chair looking up at the ceiling.
吉米靠在椅子上，抬头看着天花板。
He thinks and finally, what else?
他想，最后，还有什么呢？
Everyone sinks.
每个人都会沉沦。
It's going to be a long night.
这将是一个漫长的夜晚。
Russell starts tapping more cocaine out of a vial preparing some lines.
拉塞尔开始从小瓶中取出更多可卡因，准备一些线。
Boggs miserable, gets up from his seat and then sits down hard.
博格斯惨不忍睹，从座位上站起来，然后又重重地坐下。
He does it again.
他又这么做了。
And again, he keeps doing it.
再一次，他继续这样做。
What What are you doing?
你在做什么？
Oh, I'm going to sit on my own nuts.
哦，我要坐在我自己的坚果上。
In the hospital delivery room, Chloe is pushing.
在医院的产房里，克洛伊正在推着。
Cliff holds her hand.
克里夫握着她的手。
After one last big push, the doctor has the baby in his hands.
最后用力一推后，医生把婴儿抱到了手里。
It's a boy.
这是一个男孩。
Oh, he did it, baby.
哦，他做到了，宝贝。
You did it.
你做到了。
They kiss.
他们接吻。
The doctor inspects the baby's face, puts a stethoscope to his chest, concerned he signals the nurses.
医生检查了婴儿的脸部，将听诊器放在他的胸部，担心他会向护士发出信号。
The doctor and nurses start whispering amongst themselves.
医生和护士开始窃窃私语。
Their backs turn to Cliff and Chloe.
他们背对着克里夫和克洛伊。
pointing out and discussing unseen features of the baby.
指出并讨论婴儿看不见的特征。
Hold on.
坚持，稍等。
Cliff notices the odd huddled whispering.
克里夫注意到奇怪的挤在一起窃窃私语。
Is everything okay?
一切都好吗？
Doctor?
医生？
Is everything okay?
一切都好吗？
The huddled group keeps whispering.
挤在一起的一群人不断窃窃私语。
Outside Shane's trailer, Dave is dreading this.
在肖恩的拖车外，戴夫对此感到恐惧。
He looks over at his Ferrari with its syndicate license plate and he knows it must be done.
他看着他的法拉利，上面挂着集团牌照，他知道必须这样做。
He takes a deep breath, knocks on the door and Shane opens the door.
他深吸了一口气，敲了敲门，谢恩打开了门。
Big dog.
大狗。
I got a minute inside Shane's trailer.
我在谢恩的拖车里呆了一分钟。
Dave paces awkwardly.
戴夫笨拙地踱步。
Shane lounges on the couch.
谢恩躺在沙发上。
Dave points to one of the many posters from Shane's Broadway days.
戴夫指着谢恩百老汇时代的众多海报中的一张。
Oh, view from the bridge.
哦，从桥上看到的景色。
Oh, man.
哦，伙计。
I wish I could have seen you in that such a powerful show.
我希望能在如此精彩的演出中看到你。
Tell me one thing about that play, Dave.
告诉我关于那场戏的一件事，戴夫。
Any detail.
任何细节。
Shane, you're a consummate professional.
谢恩，你是一位完美的专业人士。
So, it's probably off-based to even ask this, but, um, you and Tanya Ray...
所以，问这个可能是不合理的，但是，嗯，你和坦尼娅·雷……
Yes?
是的？
Uh, is there anything I need to know?
呃，有什么我需要知道的吗？
Like, what exactly?
比如说，到底是什么？
Dave sits down next to Shane, acting like they're close.
戴夫坐在肖恩旁边，表现得好像他们很亲密。
Shane.
谢恩.
Bubby.
巴比。
It's me.
这就是我。
I need you to tell me the truth.
我需要你告诉我真相。
Shane smiles inscrutably like an owl about to eat a mouse.
肖恩的笑容令人费解，就像一只要吃老鼠的猫头鹰。
the truth.
事实。
Shane gets up, goes to the wall, and touches the poster from one of his Broadway triumphs, running his fingertips across it like an emotional touchstone.
肖恩站起来，走到墙边，触摸他在百老汇的一部成功作品的海报，用指尖抚摸它，就像一块情感试金石。
The truth is very important to an actor, David.
大卫，真相对于演员来说非常重要。
The most important thing, really.
最重要的是，真的。
Once at the actor studio, I was asked to improvise a scene with Jean Stapleton.
到达演员工作室后，我被要求与让·斯特普尔顿一起即兴创作一个场景。
Two lovers reunited.
两个有情人重逢了。
The scene went on for six hours, and in those six hours, we made love twice.
这场戏持续了六个小时，在这六个小时里，我们做了两次爱。
Full penetration right in front of the class.
在全班面前完全渗透。
Do you know why?
你知道为什么吗？
because it was the truth.
因为这是事实。
You fuck Theateth Bunker in front of people.
你在众人面前操Theateth Bunker。
I love theater, David, and I love New York Theater most of all, but New York is expensive.
我喜欢戏剧，大卫，我最喜欢纽约剧院，但纽约很贵。
Now, because of my Broadway success, for years Hollywood sent me a big stack of scripts every Christmas, sitcom pilots.
现在，由于我在百老汇的成功，多年来好莱坞每年圣诞节都会给我寄来一大堆剧本，情景喜剧试播集。
We love you, Shane, take your pick.
我们爱你，肖恩，选择吧。
And every year, guess which script I chose?
每年，猜猜我选择哪个剧本？
The most truthful one?
最真实的那一个？
The biggest piece of shit.
最大的一坨屎。
So that way, every spring I'd pop out to LA, shoot a pilot, make rent for the year, and then head home confident that the four-camera abortion I just sleep walked my way through would never be seen by human eyes.
这样，每年春天我都会去洛杉矶拍摄一部试播集，支付一年的租金，然后回家，相信我刚刚睡觉时走过的四镜头堕胎永远不会被人眼看到。
And that plan worked gangbusters for a long time until last year.
这个计划在很长一段时间内都取得了巨大的成功，直到去年。
Because last year, the biggest piece of shit was a piece of shit called Gimme Five.
因为去年最大的狗屎是一个叫“给我五”的狗屎。
And now, here I am, in Los Angeles under contract play Mr. P for seven years.
现在，我在洛杉矶，与 P 先生签约七年。
One of these days, I'm going to hit bottom, David.
总有一天，我会跌入谷底，大卫。
And when I finally stumble out onto the 405 to French kiss that speeding 18-wheeler and the obituary headline sums up my entire existence in a single sentence, I know one thing with absolute certainty.
当我最终偶然发现那辆高速行驶的 18 轮汽车的 405 至法式热吻，以及讣告标题用一句话概括了我的整个存在时，我绝对确定地知道一件事。
That sentence will contain the word gimme and the word five.
该句子将包含单词 gimme 和单词 5。
And I will spend eternity screaming in agony as those words are branded onto my charred flesh over and over by the devil himself in the fiery pits of hell.
我将在永恒中痛苦地尖叫，因为这些话被魔鬼在地狱的火坑里一遍又一遍地烙在我烧焦的肉体上。
The Reagan's like the show.
里根就像表演一样。
I'm not fucking Tanya Ray if that's what you're getting at.
如果你是这么想的话，我不会操坦尼娅·雷。
Oh, thank God.
哦，感谢上帝。
That is what I was getting at, and phew.
这就是我的意思，唷。
Tanya's like a daughter to me for you to come in here and accuse me of something like that.
坦尼娅对我来说就像我的女儿一样，让你来这里指责我类似的事情。
Honestly, it's insulting.
老实说，这是侮辱性的。
You're right.
你说得对。
A hundred percent.
百分之一百。
You messed up Dave.
你把戴夫搞砸了。
And now you need to be punished.
现在你需要受到惩罚。
What do you mean?
你是什​​么意思？
What do you think I mean?
你认为我的意思是什么？
I'm going to fuck Tonya Ray.
我要操托尼娅·雷。
What?
什么？
Yes.
是的。
I wasn't before.
我以前不是。
But now I am.
但现在我是了。
This is happening for two simple reasons.
发生这种情况有两个简单的原因。
One, she has an ass like baked bread.
一，她有一个像烤面包一样的屁股。
You just said she's like a daughter.
你刚才说她像个女儿。
Two, because you made this happen, Booby.
第二，因为是你让这一切发生的，布比。
Shane picks up the phone and starts dialing.
肖恩拿起电话开始拨号。
You're messing with me, right?
你是在逗我吧？
If this gets out, we'll get cancelled.
如果此事传出去，我们就会被取消。
Oh no.
哦不。
Wouldn't want that.
不想这样。
Bye, David.
再见，大卫。
Shane.
谢恩.
But Shane is already on the phone with someone.
但谢恩已经在和某人通电话了。
Chris, it's Shane.
克里斯，这是谢恩。
Oh, sweetie.
哦，亲爱的。
I just heard about your little ouchie.
我刚刚听说你的小欧奇。
Oh.
哦。
Dave is stunned.
戴夫惊呆了。
Shane waves bye-bye to him.
谢恩向他挥手告别。
In the hospital private room, Cliff and Chloe looking stunned, sit across from Dr. Dingra, an Indian woman in her 50s, who has just given them some life-changing news after a long pause.
在医院的单间里，克利夫和克洛伊一脸愕然，对面坐着丁格拉医生，一位 50 多岁的印度女性，她在长时间的沉默后刚刚给了他们一些改变生活的消息。
Down syndrome.
唐氏综合症。
No, that can't be.
不，那不可能。
But I had an amniole.
但我有羊膜。
Everything was okay.
一切都很好。
The amniole only gives a probability.
amniole 只给出一个概率。
Only when the child is born, can we know for sure?
只有孩子出生后我们才能确定吗？
I know this is hard, but we can give you a roadmap, the right therapies, the right doctors, the right schools.
我知道这很难，但我们可以为您提供路线图、正确的治疗方法、正确的医生、正确的学校。
You'd be surprised how well these kids can do.
你会对这些孩子的表现感到惊讶。
parent of a child like this will tell you there are rewards to raising a retarded child."
有这样孩子的父母会告诉你，养育一个弱智孩子是有回报的。”
That word hits Cliff like a ton of bricks.
这句话就像一大块砖头击中了克里夫。
Chloe starts to cry, shuddering.
克洛伊颤抖着开始哭泣。
Cliff holds her.
克里夫抱着她。
In the Give Me Five production office, Sarah sits in a cubicle trying to have a private phone conversation.
在《给我五》的制作办公室里，莎拉坐在小隔间里试图进行私人电话交谈。
It's not easy.
这并不容易。
I know, I'm so sorry.
我知道，我很抱歉。
I was really looking forward to dinner.
我真的很期待晚餐。
and that too.
还有那个。
I mean, definitely that too.
我的意思是，绝对也是这样。
But hey, maybe tomorrow night?
但是嘿，也许明天晚上？
No, I understand.
不，我明白。
Do you want to come over here to the office a little later?
你想稍后到办公室来一下吗？
She silently curses herself knowing this is a terrible idea.
她默默地咒骂自己，知道这是一个糟糕的主意。
In the writer's room, Sarah slips back into the room as a stressed-out Dave reads over the writer's assistant's shoulder at a typewriter.
在作家的房间里，莎拉溜回房间，而压力重重的戴夫则越过作家助理的肩膀在打字机上读书。
Are you fucking kidding me?
你他妈是在开玩笑吗？
You're still on On page three, we're very close.
你还在第三页，我们已经非常接近了。
No, page three is not very close, Jimmy.
不，第三页不太接近，吉米。
We shoot this tomorrow night, which means we rehearse it tomorrow morning, which means it needs to be done by then.
我们明天晚上拍摄，这意味着我们明天早上要排练，这意味着到那时就需要完成。
Well, you know, back on Brady, we want God to say the Brady bunch.
好吧，你知道，回到布雷迪，我们希望上帝说布雷迪那帮人。
We want to spend three days on a line.
我们想在网上花三天时间。
It was the episode where Peter wanted a new personality.
在这一集中，彼得想要一个新的人物。
Has Jimmy blathers on with yet another chestnut from behind the scenes on Brady?
吉米还在喋喋不休地讲布雷迪幕后的另一个栗子吗？
Dave looks out the window to the parking lot.
戴夫看着窗外的停车场。
Shane and Tanya Ray stand by the trailers casually chatting.
肖恩和坦尼娅·雷站在拖车旁随意聊天。
Shane looks up, sees Dave watching him, then turns to Tanya and gives her a long hug, shooting a mischievous grin at Dave the whole time.
肖恩抬起头，看到戴夫正在看着他，然后转向坦尼娅，给了她一个长长的拥抱，一直对戴夫露出顽皮的笑容。
Behind her back, Shane points to Tanya Ray, then makes the international hand signal for fucking.
肖恩在背后指着坦尼娅·雷，然后做出国际手势表示操。
Back in the writer's room, Dave watching from above is horrified.
回到作家的房间，戴夫从上面看着，惊恐万状。
And that line, of course, was pork chops and applesauce.
当然，这一行是猪排和苹果酱。
God damn it, just get it done!
该死的，快点完成吧！
Dave goes to exit, but Dottie appears in the doorway.
戴夫准备退出，但多蒂出现在门口。
Dave?
戴夫？
I just heard from Cliff.
我刚收到克里夫的消息。
Is he sick of being a dad yet?
他已经厌倦了当爸爸吗？
Can he come back and run this rewrite?
他能回来运行这个重写吗？
Something's wrong.
出了点问题。
Dave sees that Dottie is shaking, and we cut to outside the hospital.
戴夫看到多蒂在发抖，我们切到医院外面。
Dave's Ferrari screeches up outside the hospital.
戴夫的法拉利在医院外发出刺耳的声音。
In the hallway, Dave finds a grim cliff in the hall and hugs his friend.
在走廊里，戴夫发现大厅里有一个严峻的悬崖，他拥抱了他的朋友。
And the nursery a little later, Cliff and Dave are looking at the newborns behind the glass.
过了一会儿，婴儿室里的克里夫和戴夫正在看着玻璃后面的新生儿。
Are they sure?
他们确定吗？
I mean, he doesn't look any different from the others.
我的意思是，他看起来和其他人没有什么不同。
Sure.
当然。
Retarded.
迟钝。
That's the word the doctor used, retarded.
这是医生用的词，弱智。
That's supposed to be someone else's gift, you know?
那应该是别人的礼物，你知道吗？
That's the guy, back in groceries at the supermarket.
就是那个人，回到超市的杂货店。
That's not our son.
那不是我们的儿子。
When Chloe heard that word, it just broke her.
当克洛伊听到这个词时，她心碎了。
tough word.
很难听。
I close my eyes.
我闭上眼睛。
It's all I see in big red letters, and I just want to hit somebody.
我看到的都是红色的大字，我只想打某人。
All right.
好的。
Well, if that's what you need, hit that old lady.
好吧，如果你需要的话，就去打那个老太太吧。
He nods to an elderly cleaning lady just across the hall.
他向大厅对面的一位年长的清洁女工点了点头。
Cliff does not laugh.
克里夫没有笑。
Dave takes the hint.
戴夫领会了暗示。
No jokes today.
今天没有笑话。
Listen, Cliff, take as much time as you need.
听着，克里夫，你需要多少时间就花多少时间。
The show is going to be okay.
演出会顺利的。
Everything's going to be okay.
一切都会好起来的。
Silence says the two men wonder what okay even means anymore.
沉默让两个人想知道“好”到底意味着什么。
I didn't even ask.
我什至没有问。
What's his name?
他叫什么名字？
Oliver.
奥利弗.
And that's when Cliff starts to cry.
就在那时，克里夫开始哭泣。
Dave throws an arm around his friend and partners shoulder as he subs quietly.
戴夫静静地潜水，用一只手臂搂住他的朋友和伙伴的肩膀。
Back in the writer's room, sure enough the writers have ordered dinner.
回到编剧的房间，果然编剧们已经点了晚餐。
It's a somber mood.
这是一种忧郁的心情。
Where Cliff you imagine.
你想象中的悬崖。
Oh, it's just awful.
哦，这太糟糕了。
Of course, some people at Down syndrome do pretty well in life.
当然，有些患有唐氏综合症的人生活得很好。
No, it was fucking don't.
不，他妈的不这样做。
What?
什么？
You're gonna make a joke.
你会开个玩笑。
I'll never make a joke about something like this.
我绝不会拿这样的事情开玩笑。
That was a set up.
那是一个安排。
You were gonna say some people down syndrome do pretty well in life.
你可能会说有些唐氏综合症患者生活得很好。
I mean, just look at Russell.
我的意思是，看看拉塞尔。
There's now what I was gonna say.
现在我要说的是。
I thought he was going to get garbage.
我以为他会得到垃圾。
Russell does a huge line of coke, claps his hands.
拉塞尔喝了一大串可乐，拍了拍手。
Got it.
知道了。
Then Penelope says, Daddy, what's he to Santa want?
然后佩内洛普说，爸爸，圣诞老人想要什么？
During the following, Russell's nose starts bleeding.
接下来，拉塞尔的鼻子开始流血。
The blood runs down his upper lip.
血顺着他的上唇流下来。
And Mr. P's like, well, maybe Miss Claus could lose 10 pounds and buy some Victoria's Secret.
P 先生说，好吧，也许克劳斯小姐可以减掉 10 磅并买一些维多利亚的秘密。
Boom, huge noise through the roof.
轰隆隆，巨大的噪音穿过屋顶。
Russell smiles oblivious.
拉塞尔微笑着无视。
There's blood on his teeth.
他的牙齿上有血。
Oh, God.
哦，上帝。
Well, of course, I mean, she doesn't like it.
嗯，当然，我的意思是，她不喜欢这样。
Chicks aren't funny, probably on the rag, right, fellas?
小鸡们并不好笑，可能是在抹布上，对吧，伙计们？
No, your nose is on the rag.
不，你的鼻子在抹布上。
Please turn to your physical appearance, Russell.
请注意你的外表，拉塞尔。
Russell touches his face and sees blood on his fingers.
拉塞尔摸了摸自己的脸，看到手指上有血。
And don't mind me, I just got back from a romantic night with Mike Tyson.
别介意我，我刚刚和迈克·泰森度过了一个浪漫的夜晚。
But Russell looks for a napkin or a piece of paper to plug up his nose, sighing Sarah Hands and Matampong.
但拉塞尔找了一张餐巾纸或一张纸来堵住鼻子，莎拉·汉兹和马坦蓬叹了口气。
Jimmy, we've been on the same spot for hours.
吉米，我们已经在同一个地方呆了好几个小时了。
Can we just put in your Porsche joke and move on?
我们可以先讲讲你的保时捷笑话然后继续吗？
I really love that joke.
我真的很喜欢那个笑话。
I get how it's funny now.
我现在明白这有多有趣了。
A beat, as Jimmy thinks about it, finally.
吉米想，终于，节奏了。
What else?
还有什么？
Jimmy takes another bite of food and starts slowly chewing.
吉米又咬了一口食物，开始慢慢咀嚼。
One, two, three.
一二三。
Boggs begins banging his head on the table.
博格斯开始用头撞桌子。
We go to Dave's Hollywood Hills House, the rooftop patio, the most awesome 1980s Los Angeles rooftop with an amazing view and a hot tub with a topless chick in it.
我们去了 Dave's Hollywood Hills House，这里的屋顶露台是 20 世纪 80 年代洛杉矶最棒的屋顶，景色优美，还有一个热水浴缸，里面有一个赤裸上身的小妞。
But Dave's not focusing on her.
但戴夫并没有把注意力集中在她身上。
He stands at the railing, looking out at the twinkling city before him, contemplating it all.
他站在栏杆旁，看着眼前闪烁的城市，沉思着这一切。
The wind whips through his hair, which stays mostly in place thanks to all the styling moves he uses.
风吹过他的头发，由于他使用的所有造型动作，头发基本上保持在原位。
Dave has carefully staged his own deep moment.
戴夫精心上演了自己的深刻时刻。
There's a music queue in the air tonight by Phil Collins.
今晚空气中弥漫着菲尔·柯林斯 (Phil Collins) 的音乐队列。
Dave's cordless phone rings.
戴夫的无绳电话响了。
He pulls out the antenna Go for Dave and they give me five production office.
他拉出天线给戴夫，他们给了我五个生产办公室。
Dotty is at her desk concerned It's dotty.
多蒂坐在办公桌前，忧心忡忡。
Is this a bad time?
这是一个糟糕的时期吗？
Dave thinks he's a character in a Michael Mann movie.
戴夫认为他是迈克尔·曼电影中的角色。
He looks extraordinarily mellow and pensive No Just up here on the roof Looking out at the city of angels and a few devils Yeah, when life starts getting to me, I like to come up here with my horn.
他看起来格外的成熟和沉思 不 就在屋顶上 看着天使和一些魔鬼的城市 是的，当生活开始降临到我身上时，我喜欢带着我的号角来到这里。
He gestures to an alto saxophone on a stand next to him.
他指着旁边架子上的中音萨克斯管。
And shake hands with the blues.
并与布鲁斯握手。
I've got chain for you.
我有链子给你。
This kills the mood immediately.
这立刻就破坏了气氛。
Oh, god damn it.
哦，该死的。
What does he want?
他想要什么？
Dottie puts the call through in a living room.
多蒂在客厅接通了电话。
It's a living room of a young single woman in 1984.
这是 1984 年一位年轻单身女性的客厅。
Pink wall, Rob Lowe poster.
粉红色的墙，罗布·劳的海报。
Shane melts into the couch, completely fucked up, talking into a cherry red lips phone.
肖恩融化在沙发上，完全搞砸了，对着樱桃红嘴唇的电话说话。
Hello, David.
你好，大卫。
Jesus, what are you on, Shane?
天啊，你在忙什么呢，谢恩？
K-ludes and wine coolers.
K-ludes 和酒柜。
David.
大卫.
When I first met you, I thought, look at this West Coast asshole spoiled, creatively bankrupt the enemy of art.
当我第一次见到你时，我想，看看这个被宠坏的西海岸混蛋，创造性地让艺术的敌人破产了。
But now?
但现在呢？
Shane loses his train of thought.
谢恩失去了思路。
Well, what?
嗯，什么？
Shane, I have company.
谢恩，我有伴。
I don't want to fight with you, David.
我不想和你吵架，大卫。
David, we're so lucky that we get to do this for a living.
大卫，我们很幸运能够以此为生。
And I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
I've been an asshole.
我一直是个混蛋。
I am.
我是。
I'm gonna do better for the show and for you, my friend Dave doesn't know what to make of this.
我会为演出和你做得更好，我的朋友戴夫不知道该怎么办。
All he can say is Thank you Shane.
他只能说谢谢谢恩。
Also Tanya says hi.
塔尼娅也打招呼。
Say hi Tanya We reveal Tanya sitting cross-legged in her underwear playing Atari with her girlfriend also in her underwear They're both drunk off their asses Hi Tanya She laughs and Shane laughs too.
向 Tanya 打个招呼 我们展示 Tanya 穿着内衣盘腿坐着，和她也穿着内衣的女朋友一起玩雅达利游戏 他们都喝醉了 嗨 Tanya 她笑了，Shane 也笑了。
Dave does not laugh.
戴夫没有笑。
Is that Shane?
那是谢恩吗？
I swear to God Shane hangs up Shane Damn it Dave hangs up and angrily tries to put the antenna back bending it in the process The topless chicken is hot tub puffs on a joint in a roach clip after a beat.
我向上帝发誓 谢恩挂断了 谢恩该死的戴夫挂断了电话，愤怒地试图把天线放回去，在这个过程中它弯曲了。裸露上身的鸡是热水浴缸，在节拍后在蟑螂夹的关节上吹气。
She says Did you hear about mr.
她说你听说过先生吗？
Balvedere in the writer's room?
巴尔韦德尔在作家的房间里？
It's deep into the night Everyone's exhausted, sitting in silence, trying to think of the joke that gets them out of here.
夜已深了，每个人都精疲力尽，默默地坐着，试图想出能让他们离开这里的笑话。
There's a knock at the door.
有人敲门。
They all look up.
他们都抬起头来。
A guy who's sort of handsome in an 80s kind of way is standing in the doorway.
门口站着一个有点80年代风范的帅哥。
Sarah sees him and gets up.
莎拉看到他，站了起来。
Hi, sorry.
嗨，抱歉。
I'll be back in ten minutes.
我十分钟后回来。
She takes the guy by the hand and leads him down the hall into the women's bathroom.
她拉着那家伙的手，领着他穿过走廊，走进女洗手间。
Bog sees this wide-eyed, holy shit.
博格看到这一切，天哪。
Exterior of Los Angeles, hours go by, night passes, the sun comes up over the city.
洛杉矶郊外，时间流逝，夜晚过去，太阳升起在城市上空。
In the hospital private room at dawn, light creeps through the curtains, Chloe is asleep in bed.
黎明时分，医院的单间里，光线透过窗帘透进来，克洛伊正在床上睡着。
Cliff sits with baby Oliver in his lap.
克里夫坐在他的腿上，小奥利弗坐在他的腿上。
He looks down at his son in the early morning light, trying to understand him.
他在清晨的阳光下低头看着儿子，试图理解他的想法。
Oliver coos gently, reflexively cliff smiles, a lovely little moment of communion between father and son.
奥利弗轻轻地咕咕叫着，反射性地露出悬崖般的微笑，这是父子之间可爱的交流时刻。
Despite all the pain, Cliff really does love this boy.
尽管有这么多的痛苦，克里夫真的很爱这个男孩。
The phone rings, a loud old school bell, the baby starts to fuss, cliff size and answers it.
电话铃响了，是一声响亮的老式学校铃声，婴儿开始大惊小怪，然后接了电话。
Hello.
你好。
In the Gimme 5 production office, it's boggs, calling surreptitiously from the bullpen.
在《给我 5》的制作办公室里，是沼泽在牛棚里偷偷地打电话。
The office is dark, the only light coming from the writer's room in the distance.
办公室很黑，唯一的灯光来自远处的作家房间。
Boggs whispers conspiratorially.
博格斯阴谋般地低声说道。
It's a boggs.
这是一个沼泽。
Sorry to bother you, but there's some bad shit going down on me here.
很抱歉打扰你，但我这里有一些不好的事情。
Well, Boggs, I wish you strength in this year hour of need.
好吧，博格斯，我祝愿你在今年最需要的时候坚强起来。
Okay, yeah, yeah, you're right, I'm sorry.
好吧，是的，是的，你说得对，对不起。
I know you guys are having a hard time, and this doesn't compare, but yeah, this is a fucking nightmare.
我知道你们正经历着一段艰难的时光，这无法比较，但是，是的，这真是一场噩梦。
Jimmy kept us here all night, and we're just still on page five.
吉米让我们整晚都在这儿，而我们才读到第五页。
Five.
五。
I know you don't want to deal with this song, so all you need to say are four little words.
我知道你不想处理这首歌，所以你只需说四个字。
Boggs, you're in charge.
博格斯，你负责。
Say those words, and I promise you.
说这些话，我向你保证。
Is there anything else, Bugs?
还有什么吗，巴格斯？
Ugh, I think Sarah blew a guy in the ladies' room.
呃，我觉得莎拉在女厕所里给了一个男人口交。
Cliff hangs up, revealed Chloe having woken up.
克里夫挂断电话，透露克洛伊已经醒了。
I'm sorry, I can't believe those idiots would call me here and try to- Buddha work.
抱歉，我不敢相信那些白痴会把我叫到这里并试图——佛陀工作。
Exit.
出口。
Cliff has taken it back.
克里夫把它收回了。
What?
什么？
No, you need me here.
不，你需要我在这里。
What if I said the thought of you smiling in a writer's room made me happier than the thought of you frowning in that chair?
如果我说想到你在作家的房间里微笑比想到你在那张椅子上皱眉更让我高兴呢？
You actually think I can go back to writing dumb jokes?
你真的认为我可以回去写愚蠢的笑话吗？
now.
现在。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
Because nothing's funny.
因为没有什么好笑的。
Nothing will ever be funny again.
没有什么会再变得有趣了。
I just can't.
我就是不能。
You can.
你可以。
You have to.
你必须这样做。
Why are you saying this?
你为什么这么说？
All right, you hate my job.
好吧，你讨厌我的工作。
You never see me, you think I'm a better writer than this shit?
你从来没见过我，你以为我是比这狗屎更好的作家吗？
Why would I go back there?
我为什么要回到那里？
therapies, doctors, special schools, all the things the doctor talked about, the things that can make our son's life better.
疗法、医生、特殊学校，医生谈论的所有事情，可以让我们儿子的生活变得更好的事情。
They cost money.
他们要花钱。
Lots of it.
很多。
So go write dumb jokes, Cliff.
所以去写一些愚蠢的笑话吧，克里夫。
Write them until we're rich.
写下来，直到我们变得富有。
Write them until we're so fucking rich that when we die, Oliver will be okay.
写下来，直到我们变得非常富有，这样当我们死后，奥利弗就会没事。
Forever.
永远。
That's why.
这就是原因。
Cliff takes this in.
克里夫接受了这一点。
He looks down, angle on Oliver, sweetly sleeping, cradled in Cliff's two hands.
他低下头，看着奥利弗，克里夫两只手抱着他，睡得很香。
We match cut to the writer's room.
我们将镜头匹配到编剧的房间。
Dave holding page three of the script in his hands.
戴夫手里拿着剧本的第三页。
Dave looks up, Stairs, a Jimmy, a gape, and then...
戴夫抬起头，斯泰尔斯，吉米，目瞪口呆，然后……
Is this a practical joke?
这是一个恶作剧吗？
Are Dick Clark and Ed McMahon hiding under the table?
迪克·克拉克和艾德·麦克曼藏在桌子底下吗？
Some jokes take longer than others.
有些笑话比其他笑话需要更长的时间。
Do you, assholes, know how hard it is to get out of a waterbed when there's a Hawaiian Tropic Model lying in it wearing nothing but a G-string, and one of those tops where you only see the bottom of her boobs?
你们这些混蛋知道吗，当夏威夷热带模特躺在水床上，只穿着丁字裤，穿着一件只能看到胸部底部的上衣时，从水床上爬出来有多困难？
Because that's what I had to do this morning at 7am, so I could come here to rehearse a script that you haven't fucking written yet.
因为这就是我今天早上七点必须做的事情，所以我可以来这里排练你他妈还没写好的剧本。
Are you kidding me?
你在开玩笑吧？
Hey guys, Dave turns around and there's Cliff in the doorway.
嘿伙计们，戴夫转过身来，克里夫就在门口。
Dave drops the page stunned.
戴夫震惊地放下了页面。
It's awkward.
很尴尬。
Everyone here knows Cliff said situation, but nobody says a word.
这里的每个人都知道克里夫所说的情况，但没有人说一句话。
What page we own?
我们拥有哪个页面？
Oh, nothing much, just a Porsche 944.
哦，没什么，只是一辆保时捷 944。
Cliff's non-reaction speaks volumes.
克里夫的冷漠反应很能说明问题。
Hey, it's funny in several weeks.
嘿，几周后就会很有趣。
It will get a laugh.
它会引起笑声。
Did anyone here laugh at it?
这里有人笑吗？
What's laughter?
什么是笑？
It's Russell's out of cocaine voice.
这是拉塞尔失去可卡因的声音。
Cliff sits at the head of the table.
克里夫坐在桌子的首位。
Everyone perks up.
大家精神抖擞。
All right, we can beat this.
好吧，我们可以打败这个。
Mr. P, what treat do you think Santo wants?
P先生，您认为Santo想要什么款待？
Well, honey.
好吧，亲爱的。
And we flashed to the Pendleton living room, the same Christmas scene we saw earlier.
我们闪到彭德尔顿的客厅，和我们之前看到的圣诞场景一模一样。
Santa's had a long night.
圣诞老人度过了一个漫长的夜晚。
Pour a little Scotch in a cup, then leave Santa the rest of the bottle.
在杯子里倒一点苏格兰威士忌，然后把剩下的瓶子留给圣诞老人。
Back to the writer's room.
回到编剧的房间。
gets the room's attention.
引起房间的注意。
It's not bad.
这还不错。
Yeah.
是的。
Drunk.
醉。
Santa's kind of funny.
圣诞老人有点有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Santa drinking.
圣诞老人喝酒。
Scott feels a little edgy.
斯科特感觉有点急躁。
Are we sure we like that better than the Porsche joke?
我们确定我们比保时捷笑话更喜欢这个吗？
Yes.
是的。
Jesus.
耶稣。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
He had never any buffet of thick black cocks, Jimmy.
他从来没有吃过粗黑鸡巴的自助餐，吉米。
Okay.
好的。
Scott's joke.
斯科特的笑话。
It is.
这是。
Let's put it in and move on.
让我们把它放进去然后继续。
No one laughed at that either.
也没有人嘲笑这一点。
Come on.
快点。
Let's keep thinking.
让我们继续思考。
Well, do we even need a joke here?
好吧，我们还需要开玩笑吗？
Steve looks up from his typewriter.
史蒂夫从打字机上抬起头来。
Are you fucking kidding me?
你他妈是在开玩笑吗？
Whoa, Jimmy broke Steve.
哇哦，吉米伤了史蒂夫。
Could it just be something like?
难道只是像这样吗？
We flashed to the living room the same Christmas scene we saw earlier.
我们把之前看到的同样的圣诞节场景闪到客厅。
Oh, Santa already has the perfect treat right here.
哦，圣诞老人已经在这里得到了完美的款待。
The five of you.
你们五个人。
Oh.
哦。
Back to the writer's room, the writer's glare at Jimmy.
回到作家的房间，作家怒视着吉米。
The audience loves and everything's going to be okay moment.
观众喜欢，一切都会好起来的时刻。
Cliff thinks about this, gets a little twinkle in his eye.
克里夫想到这里，眼中闪过一丝光芒。
Everything's going to be okay.
一切都会好起来的。
Okay.
好的。
It's a good angle, Jimmy.
这是一个很好的角度，吉米。
All right.
好的。
Building off of that.
以此为基础。
Back to the same Christmas scene, Mr. P.
回到同一个圣诞节场景，P 先生。
gestures to Lacey, Tanya Ray.
向莱西（Tanya Ray）示意。
Santa already has the perfect treat right here.
圣诞老人已经在这里得到了完美的款待。
Your sister's hot wet pussy.
你姐姐的阴部又热又湿。
The studio audience gasps.
演播室的观众倒吸一口冷气。
Back to the writer's room.
回到编剧的房间。
Everyone cracks up.
每个人都崩溃了。
Most of all, Dave, this hits close to home.
最重要的是，戴夫，这很切中要害。
Even Cliff laughs at his own joke.
就连克里夫也被自己的笑话逗笑了。
It feels good.
感觉很好。
He was certain he'd never laugh again.
他确信自己再也不会笑了。
No, no, not cool.
不，不，不酷。
But Dave is laughing, Russell jumps up, acting it out.
但戴夫在笑，拉塞尔跳起来，表演出来。
Yeah, and then Mr. P stands up and he bends Lacey over the couch and he just starts, wow, we're going right there in front of everybody.
是的，然后 P 先生站起来，他把莱西压在沙发上，然后他就开始说，哇，我们就在大家面前去那里。
The room laughs at Lacey's leg.
房间里的人都在嘲笑莱西的腿。
Back in the living room, the other kids watch on an abject horror as Mr. Pendleton and Lacey go at it on the couch.
回到客厅，其他孩子惊恐地看着彭德尔顿先生和莱西在沙发上做这件事。
Oh, yeah, Mr. P.
哦，是的，P 先生。
Back in the writer's room, the laughter continues.
回到编剧室，笑声仍在继续。
Give me five, give me five.
给我五个，给我五个。
like give me 15 bitch.
就像给我15个母狗一样。
A huge laugh.
一阵大笑。
Cliff takes the ball and runs with it as the room cracks up for Cliff.
克利夫接球并带着球跑动，房间里的气氛为克利夫而开。
This is like oxygen.
这就像氧气。
We are watching a man come back to life.
我们正在看着一个人复活。
Yes, that's perfect.
是的，那就完美了。
Steve get all this down.
史蒂夫记下这一切。
Steve cracking up and going with the joke starts typing.
史蒂夫开怀大笑，开始打字。
Mr. P keeps fucking her as we cut to a shot of the live studio audience.
当我们切换到现场演播室观众的镜头时，P 先生继续操她。
Everyone's losing their shit.
每个人都失去了他们的狗屎。
They all start throwing up on each other.
他们都开始互相呕吐。
Then we cut to Nancy Reagan watching in the White House while Ronnie's fucking her up the ashram behind and he's like, oh yeah, mommy, here come the jelly beans.
然后我们切到南希·里根在白宫观看，而罗尼正在后面的静修处操她，他就像，哦，是的，妈妈，糖豆来了。
And then he blows his load.
然后他就炸毁了他的负载。
And then she shits out all onto the carpet and then the shit jizz.
然后她把所有东西都吐到地毯上，然后是屎精液。
It actually spells out Merry Christmas from give me five.
它实际上拼出了“给我五个”的“圣诞快乐”。
Everything's gonna be okay.
一切都会好起来的。
Yeah, fucking guns.
是啊，该死的枪。
The end.
结束。
Everyone is losing their minds with laughter.
大家都笑得发疯了。
It's not particularly funny, but these people People have been up all night.
这不是特别好笑，但是这些人一夜没睡。
Bogs and Russell are practically crying.
博格斯和拉塞尔几乎哭了。
Oh God, why are we laughing at this?
天哪，我们为什么要笑这个？
It's where a bunch of fucking retards.
这里就是一群该死的弱智的地方。
And all of a sudden Cliff punches Russell in the face hard, breaking his nose.
突然，克里夫狠狠地打了拉塞尔的脸，打断了他的鼻子。
Russell falls to the floor.
拉塞尔摔倒在地。
The laughter dies quickly.
笑声很快就消失了。
Russell looks up stunned.
拉塞尔惊愕地抬起头。
Nobody can believe what just happened.
没有人相信刚刚发生的事情。
Least of all Cliff, there's a long beat of silence.
最重要的是克里夫，有一段长时间的沉默。
And we hard cut to the Pendleton living room, the actual show.
我们硬切到彭德尔顿的客厅，真正的表演。
The live studio audience watches the Christmas scene.
现场演播室观众观看圣诞节场景。
Mr. P, what treat do you think Santa wants?
P先生，你认为圣诞老人想要什么礼物？
Oh, nothing much.
哦，没什么。
Just a Porsche 944.
只是一辆保时捷 944。
Huge laugh, the audience eats it up.
笑点大，观众都吃得津津有味。
In the darkness at the edge of the stage, Cliff watches by himself.
在舞台边缘的黑暗中，克里夫独自观看。
The writers, Dave, Bog, Sarah, Russell, with his nose bandaged and Jimmy, stand closer, listening to the laughter.
编剧们，戴夫、博格、莎拉、拉塞尔，鼻子上缠着绷带，吉米则站得更近，听着笑声。
Jimmy Smiles, satisfied.
吉米满意地微笑。
It got a laugh.
它得到了笑声。
All right, there you have it.
好吧，给你了。
Gimme five, so funny, so moving.
给我五，太有趣了，太感人了。
Just a really incredible piece of work.
这真是一件令人难以置信的作品。
And that would just be sitting on the cloud or in hard drives, Carter and Craig's hard drives, if it was not for dead pilot society.
如果不是死亡飞行员社会，这些数据只会存在于云端或硬盘中，卡特和克雷格的硬盘中。
I think that's something that's worth supporting that we get these shows, we bring them to life, we make them available for you to listen to, the writers get to hear their work, no one else is doing this.
我认为这是值得支持的事情，我们得到这些节目，我们将它们带入生活，我们让它们可供您收听，编剧们可以听到他们的作品，没有其他人在这样做。
I hope you, you're motivated to become a part of the Dead Pilots Society by going to maximumfund.org slash join Dead Pilots and becoming a member, or if you're already a member, Think about boosting or upgrading.
我希望您有动力成为死亡飞行员协会的一员，通过访问maximumfund.org 加入死亡飞行员协会并成为会员，或者如果您已经是会员，请考虑提升或升级。
We've got a great year of pilots we're gonna be bringing you and we'd love for your support as a member.
我们将给您带来美好的一年的试点，我们希望您作为会员给予支持。
All right, thanks so much.
好的，非常感谢。
We'll be back with a lot more this week, including the second half of my interview with Carter and Craig and more of our countdown of the top five funniest cold opens in dead pilot society history.
本周我们将带来更多内容，包括我对卡特和克雷格采访的后半部分，以及更多关于死亡飞行员社会历史上最有趣的前五名冷开场的倒计时。
Okay, you'll be hearing more from me very soon, but thanks so much for listening.
好的，您很快就会收到我的更多消息，但非常感谢您的聆听。
I'm Andrew Reich.
我是安德鲁·赖克。
Until next time, take care.
直到下次，保重。